[Music]
question party is very simple you guys
in the audience are gonna ask me and
tara questions and we're gonna answer
them yeah
and it's gonna be fun like a party so if
you have a question just raise your hand
and if we call on you stand up and ask
it ask it nice and loud so we can hear
you yes but don't pull down that mask we
want to answer your questions and not
spread aerosol droplets that's right so
let's do this who has a question for me
and tarek
uh so now that you guys are so famous do
you have to go out and call like uh
disguises around the city
she said now that you guys are so famous
do you have to go around the city in
disguises
no
i'm also that's very kind of including
me in there
i don't know i know who the hell i am
[Applause]
also if you see me without my makeup and
you recognize me i will be mad yeah
do you think that is this lady i'd be so
pissed i get confused for every other
black guy on the street so it's just
didn't you play webster
no i didn't i didn't but there will be a
live action webster i will be
i will play wesley
i'm sorry you guys that's all the time
we have for question party this was
great should we do it again sometimes
[Music]
[Applause]
you